what's shaking people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today
june 7th 2021
uh as always uh subscribe to our youtube
channel
tap that notification bell and i've been
told to remind you to share
these videos using your computer device
or handheld
technological thing that you've got in
your pocket you can click the link you
can share it
and then other people will see these
videos it's very very exciting
i hope everybody had a great weekend i
did it was very
chill around here we had some family
visiting a lot of food
a lot of pool time i did not do politics
over the weekend
suffice to say that on friday afternoon
a little project that dave rubin had
been working on for about six years
came to fruition i finally finally
fully red pilled my brother-in-law
i had been working on this for a long
long time
and i made it happen i doled out the
final pill
it was in the hot tub with some tequila
which helps
but once the final pill was swallowed he
looked at me and he said
well this sucks but i get it
and thus the adventure can begin pretty
good all right guys we've got four
stories for you today
uh this joe biden fella he gave a
commencement speech at the white house
he didn't actually go
to any universities i guess they did
this online so they could send it
to a bunch of college graduates and he's
warning people
that systemic racism and climate change
they're coming to get you and he's going
to fix those things even though
he never did it in 47 years of public
office before he just became president
then if you want to see just a master
class
in what just blew a non sort of
worthless journalist slash
worthless uh figurehead for an
administration
sound like well jenn pasaki was on brian
stelter's
ironically named reliable sources this
weekend it is literally the most
ironically named
television show in the history of the
world it's called reliable sources
brian stilter is probably the most
unreliable person perhaps on television
and the show's called i mean call it
unreliable sources then we've got no
problem but you call it reliable sources
anyway he just did the worst sort of
softball interview with pasaki and we'll
dive into that
and then i thought we'd do a little
story on how country
states are going in different directions
we've had a divergence
there's a divergence in the force and
washington
of course a blue state they are
instilling critical race theory in
schools while
florida a red state uh is actually
banning critical race theory in schools
and that is not an infringement on the
first amendment or on free speech i'll
get into that in a little bit
and then for the fourth story as long as
we're talking about florida because
they're doing it right in florida and
i'm going to florida next week by the
way and i'll be interviewing
on location uh the mayor of miami
francis suarez who's just doing an
absolutely freaking unbelievable job
in welcoming thousands and thousands of
people who are leaving san francisco he
has turned miami into an absolute
incredible tech hub they had a bitcoin
conference over the weekend like there's
just so much going on down there
i can't wait to get down there in case
you can't tell he is also
banning trans girls in sports so
biological boys who want to play in
girls sports and beat the crap out of
girls and dunk on girls
and things of that nature uh well ron
desantis is taking the
uh highly controversial opinion of
saying no you can't do that
so we'll get into all of that um so
first story
let's talk about this joe biden guy he
gave a commencement speech
you know he just reads off the prompter
sometimes he's good at it sometimes he
isn't he didn't have any major flubs
on this one but here he warned
the college graduate the college
graduates of 2021
he warned them about the two biggest
threats that they'll be facing in their
lifetimes
and now you face another inflection
point
as we put this pandemic behind us
rebuild our economy
root out systemic racism and tackle
climate change
we're addressing the great crises of our
time
with a greater sense of purpose than
ever before and because of you
your generation i've never been more
optimistic about the future than i am
today
all right so let's just be clear about a
couple things here joe biden has been in
office
over 47 years the fact that he never
uttered the phrase systemic racism
until the last year in essence you know
sort of a year and a half when he
started running for president
this time around sort of tells you that
that's just made up on its face
also the fact that i guess he didn't
really do anything about climate change
in 47 years i mean it's just sort of
hysterical nonsense but they want
the base and especially the young people
to feel like there are these
massive things that if only you give
them enough money of course and enough
power and enough control over your life
that if that then you can fix these
things of course these things probably
can't be fixed
uh first because you know that systemic
racism one it doesn't exist
okay it does not exist there is no
racism
in the system that is the laws of the
united
states if there were laws that said
black people can't do this
white people get extra benefits to do
this asian people can't do this any of
that kind of stuff
then i would actually uh be against
those things i would be fighting
for equality for all people and that's
what's guaranteed to us
in the constitution of the united states
over the years we have had laws that
were racist jim crow laws for example
we've done some bad things japanese
internment things of that nature
and then we've always fought to get rid
of those things so when joe biden tells
you that systemic racism
exists not only is he lying and if it if
he isn't lying well then he's been part
of it this entire time
um but he's using something that doesn't
really exist just to further whatever
his political goals are and i don't even
think he knows what his political goals
are
his political goals are goals are
whatever his handlers
goals are right i mean like we all know
that uh if you want to talk about
systemic racism if you're talking about
affirmative action
that we give money to people based on
the color of their skin well that might
be something related to systemic racism
or that in the covid relief bill that
you just pushed we started giving more
to black and brown farmers and less to
white farmers we covered that a couple
weeks ago that's kind of
systemic racism that that would be that
kind of stuff but i'm pretty sure that's
not what joe
is talking about and then as far as
climate change as i've said many times
and i've had people on the show to talk
about
climate change the issue is not whether
the climate is changing the issue is not
scientific consensus or any of those
things
the issue is what can if anything we do
about it as a
as a nation and as a world and if you
think that just
passing the aoc's green new deal
is a good idea like to just rejigger the
economy so that aoc can have whatever
she wants
climate by the way she told us that the
world's ending in 12 years that was
about two years ago we only got 10 years
anyway
uh but meanwhile aoc did you see this
this was on friday
uh she posted a picture of her abuela uh
in puerto rico who uh
is living in strife apparently she's
living in a very dilapidated building
and she aoc claimed that it was because
trump held up
relief after the storms in puerto rico
now that was a year and a half ago and i
guess for some reason aoc she makes 180
grand a year she has a tesla she lives
in a very elite
building in dc i guess for some reason
she didn't want to put together or
fundraise or anything anything to help
her abuela so matt walsh over at the
daily wire
he put together a gofundme for aoc's
abuela
and uh it raised over a hundred thousand
dollars
that the aoc team rejected so all that
money has been dispersed back to people
i threw in some money
uh i also offered to give a spanish copy
of don't burn this book which just came
out last week the official spanish
translation
of don't burn this book but anyway the
point is
yes aoc salary is 174 000. thank you
very much i said 180 000. i don't you
know those 6 000 bucks
that changes the equation you know if
she had made 880 she could have helped
abuela 174
um anyway i played this video for you
the biden thing because it's like
these are not real issues there are so
many bigger issues that are happening to
us right this very moment violence
in our streets critical race theory that
we're going to talk about
brainwashing our children the
hyper-racialization
of everything the encroachment now of
china what's going on
with kovid and was it leaked and then
are we at war at that point like there's
there's so many real things but they
don't want you to think about the real
things they want you to think about
systemic racism
which doesn't exist and climate change
which you can't do much about
again that's not to say you shouldn't do
anything and we do recycle around here
and there should be some
probably some public private partnership
to deal with some of that stuff we did a
friday panel on climate change a couple
weeks ago
if you want more of my thoughts on that
before we move on people i want to talk
to you
about raycon you know as you know once a
year i like to go off the grid for the
month of august i
cannot wait to do it this year after
spending the last year cooped up at home
i'm excited to be traveling again and
looking forward to a real summer
vacation
we're not sure where we're gonna go yet
actually if you have any uh any ideas on
where we should go let us know in the
comments
whether it's for work or play a lot of
us are gonna be on the move again this
summer
so my advice is to you my advice to you
is to take your ray-cons with you
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference
you get crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons look great and feel even better
they come in a range of
colors and have customizable gel tips
included for a comfortable
in-ear fit and raycons are built to go
everywhere you wherever you go with
quick and seamless bluetooth pairing
and a compact charging case i use them
when i'm doing
cardio to my ronald reagan speeches
which not the fastest cardio ever but it
does the trick
listen up guys raycon is offering 15 off
all their products for my listeners and
here's what you've got to do to get it
go to buy raycon.com ruben there you'll
get 15
off your entire recon order and it's
such a good deal you'll want to grab a
pair and maybe a spare
that's 15 off at byraycon.com ruben buy
recon dot com slash reuben
and now back to reuben all right so
brian stelter this is this potato clown
guy that's on cnn
he hosts a show called reliable sources
and this is their sunday news recap show
and i i kid you not you know i've always
been
sort of a student of the media of
tv and politics i always loved all this
stuff
even really it started when i was about
10 years old i sort of remember
when i was sort of into this stuff and
my dad would be watching these things
and i would be watching them
and it used to be reliable sources used
to be hosted by a guy
by the name of howard kurtz who now is
on fox news but it was basically
like they would talk about like what's
going on in the media what are our blind
spots
can we do something better can we really
hold power to account howard kurtz i
thought did a pretty nice
job doing it and he do he does a similar
show if i'm not mistaken on on fox
these days but anyway brian stelter took
over from him i think it's probably
about 10 years ago or so
something like that and stelter's just
awful if you want to just see like the
type of person that's just part of the
machine and just wants to like suck up
to all of the worst people constantly
and when he thought things were horrible
under trump now the same things
happen under biden but you know we don't
talk about them anymore or we
somehow obfuscate them or whatever it
might be well first just listen to this
question you're going to get the answer
from pasaki but listen to the question
that stelter asks pasaki here's clip one
what does the press get wrong when
covering
biden's agenda when you watch the news
when you read the news
what do you think we get wrong well
look i think some of our muscles have
atrophied a little bit over the last few
years
and there isn't a lot of memory or
recent memory or long
longer memory on how long it takes to
get legislation forward
or how messy the process of negotiating
and the process of getting legislation
across the finish line
can be so we know we understand
everybody's always looking for a
deadline a timeline
things like that but at the end of the
day our focus is on
getting these bills across the finish
line doing it in a bipartisan way if we
can
and we certainly recognize that that can
be messy along the process so
i don't know if that's the press getting
it wrong i'll leave you to the critique
of that brian but
i think sometimes we forget how strange
the last four years were and when we
returned to a place where
democracy is working where we're talking
with democrats and republicans where
we're trying to get bills and
legislation passed
yes when we return to a place when
democracy is working when we're all
blowing each other constantly and nobody
is saying anything
remotely close to true i mean forget her
answer she's just she's just the worst
but his question what does the press get
wrong why would you ask the press
secretary that
that's the person you're supposed to be
challenging that's the person who is the
face
of the white house every day out there
with the press that's the person you
should be asking
all the most incisive questions that's
the most the person you should be asking
all the most pressing questions that you
should be
pushing and prodding to get to something
closer to truth and he said
what does the press get wrong when
covering the biden agenda that is the
worst sort of oh
i mean they literally stelter is
basically a puppy who wants a cookie
that's all he is he's a little a fat
little puppy
who you know some puppies are you know
he got into the cookie jar too much but
he's just down there
like please can i have another cookie
can i have another cookie that's
i want a cookie all right if you didn't
think that was bad enough then
stelter asks pasaki because she's known
to speak
truth he asks her about truth
for journalists who watch what you do
what's your advice for them about
trying to stay hid close to the truth in
this world of lies
well i think what i try to do is stay
grounded to the facts
and what i mean by that the details and
what we can help
provide publicly to clarify context to
make it more understandable to the press
to the public
and it sometimes it's not more
complicated than that
oh lord give me the strength it's only
monday
forget again forget her answer she just
says words like it's just word word word
noun adjective adverb okay she's just
saying nothing but that's her job to say
nothing
but asking the press secretary
about truth you
stelter you're one of the prime
purveyors of
lies you push the russia hoax the
covington kids hoax
the brett kavanaugh hoax we can go on
and on about the lies
that you push every week then there was
this other thing last week speaking of
stelter and his network cnn
where jake tapper said that he won't
have liars on his show anymore and he
was talking about a couple
republicans uh who were defending trump
you know over election stuff a few
months ago that he's not going to have
these liars
on his show anymore and then uh what's
her name stefanik what's what's her
first name elise
stefanik i believe uh who is a
congresswoman out of new york i think
maybe staten island if i'm not mistaken
she posted screenshots it's actually
spectacular of
tapper's people asking her to come on
the show
at the same time while he's saying he's
not going to talk to these people
they're
all liars they're liars and they're
it's as if they're like laundering the
lies with each other
so you get stelter talking to pasaki
it's his job to lie it's her job to lie
let's all launder the lies together and
we'll all lie
all the time and as i quote all the time
now this alternates in quote
we know that they know they're lying we
know they're lying
they know that we know they're lying and
they continue to lie
well it's just gonna keep going people
it is just bananas but okay
i'm gonna give you a story here we're
gonna talk about critical race theory i
know you guys
know all about critical race theory we
have talked about it quite
endlessly this is a horrific set of
ideas that
implies that the united states founding
principles were racism that things like
being on time
and working hard and doing your job that
these are somehow white characteristics
which if they are white characteristics
then it seems like white supremacists
would be
a pretty great bunch of people who would
be pretty productive that you'd want to
be around
i mean the whole thing is just backwards
nonsense you all know that but in
some places in the united states they're
actually officially
putting it into schools and in other
places in the united states
they're actually getting rid of it so
we've got some quotes here from the
federalists
and this starts us with washington state
as several states move to ban
toxic critical race theory from
indoctrinating students the state of
washington
is leaning in the race obsessed
framework
isn't relegated to schools in seattle
where you'd expect a victim-centered
ideology like critical race theory to
flourish
thanks to the state's
democrat-controlled legislature
a trio of bills just signed into law
mandates critical race theory
training for all public school teachers
another even requires training for
medical students teaching them that it's
essential to be social justice activists
as it is to treat patients staffers
learn that black people cannot be racist
because they don't have
power that whites benefit from white
privilege even if they experience
high poverty and that virtually every
american institution
is founded in white supremacy okay so
washington you're not a good place i say
that with all due irony i'm here in
california
not a good place either but understand
that systemic racism the stuff that joe
biden was talking about
in story number one that doesn't really
exist they are the ones
putting it into the system they are
going to train
a generation of young people through
training a generation of teachers
that somehow black people can't be
racist i mean jemele hill
is a racist um all of the people pushing
critical race theory
are racists right we know this if
i you can be a racist i don't care what
your skin color is i don't care for
these semantic games
that they want to play if you're a black
person and you want white people to be
treated differently under the law
and you don't like white people just
because the color of their skin you're a
racist and saying goes if you're a white
person and you don't want black people
or whatever it is
you're a racist too like stop playing
these we're all playing these ridiculous
semantic games
with these people who would never afford
us the the opportunity to
be wide in our thoughts but we're
supposed to always give them
the absolute benefit of the doubt then i
saw this morning
that randy weingarten who's the head of
the teachers union and this woman is
just completely
bananas if you don't think she's bananas
go look at her twitter flag her avatar
is the flag it's the trans flag with the
black and brown flag
on top of it and another flag on top of
it and a flag on top of that the woman
believes in everything and when you
believe in everything you actually
believe in nothing
can you guys tell them caffeinated this
morning um
well i saw a tweet from her where she
tweets out an article by the aclu
claiming that right-wingers are trying
to stop
people from learning about racism in
schools and it's just a complete lie
it's not that right-wingers are stopping
anyone from teaching racism at school if
you go to any public school you learn
about slavery
you learn about the history of america
you learn all of those things i've never
heard a conservative person or a
crazy right winger say we can't talk
about racism or we can't talk about
slavery or we can't have an honest
assessment
of the history of the united states what
they're trying to ban is critical race
theory which is
race essentialism in schools which is
telling white people that they are
less while telling black people that
they are more this is the reverse of
that martin luther king thing i know you
know it already
but these people they're all liars and
buffoons and i don't know what we're
supposed to do with them
anyway there are some decent people
around ron desantis who of course
is the governor of the great state of
florida can we reach out to him when i'm
there next week let's see if we can pull
something off all right we all we
already have all right
let's see if i can get a meeting with uh
with governor desantis
uh he is banning critical race theory in
florida but don't take my word for it
let's listen to him
this proposition that we are a
systemically racist country
your reaction well it's a bunch of horse
manure i mean
give me a break this country uh has had
more opportunity for more people
than any country in the history of the
world and it doesn't matter where you
trace your ancestry from
we've had people that have been able to
succeed and all and here's the problem
with things like critical race theory
that they're peddling
they're basically saying all our
institutions are are bankrupt
and they're they're illegitimate okay so
how do you have a society
if everything in your society is
illegitimate so it's a very harmful
ideology
and i would say uh really a a race-based
version
of of a marxist type ideology so we've
banned it in our schools here in florida
we're not going to put any taxpayer
dollars to critical race theory
and we want to treat people as
individuals not as members of groups
god that is what a decent public servant
looks and sounds like that is someone
who does not want a generation
of people to be brainwashed that is
someone who wants people to be free
and talks about the individual which is
the most fundamental building block that
we've got here
in the united states i mean that is just
please become president ron desantis
oh please let it happen let it happen uh
but if you don't think that's enough
uh oh oh i want to actually address one
other thing he says when he's talking
about the institutions if
if your point is and this is their point
that all of the institutions are
fundamentally evil and
and whatever and i by the way i sort of
agree at this point
the institutions are evil but not
because of them being racist it's
because these people have overtaken the
institutions right
their argument is that all of the
institutions our political institutions
our cultural institutions all of our
um all of our businesses our
corporations their argument is that
they're all racist
thus evil no they weren't and they
haven't been
they now as these people have infected
the host right the alien
uh analogy that i always give they've
taken over the body
they're the ones that have made these
things racist
okay that is the problem uh but if you
don't think what desantis is doing on
critical race there is good enough
he also i wanted to play this last week
on june 1st which was the first day of
lgbt plus whatever whatever
pride month he banned
trans girls meaning biological
boys from competing in women's sports
and people were
very upset about this saying he's
attacking trans people on day one he's
banning trans people from sports
before i show you the video let's just
be very clear about something he's not
banning anyone from sports he's saying
you have to play
in the division that is correlated with
your biological sex
thus girls can compete against
biological girls
and we don't want boys competing
against biological girls so that they
can dunk on them or
choke them or run faster than them that
would have been the feminist
feminist position of 20 years ago now
it's some sort of right wing radical
stuff but
let's listen to desantis i can tell you
this in florida
you know girls are going to play girls
sports and boys are going to play boys
sports that's what we're doing
and we're going to make sure that that's
the reality the bill that we're doing
today will ensure fairness
for women athletes for years to come in
the state of florida
it says that athletic teams or sports
that are designated for females are open
to females and we're going to go based
off biology
not based off ideology when we're doing
sports
biology not ideology that pretty much
nails it right you know what's
interesting about listening to desantis
we are subjugated to
so many ridiculous politicians
hysterical
lunacy from bernie sanders and aoc
constantly swinging her arms
and all and and biden mumbling through
things we're so
subjected to ridiculousness at at all
times
that i find when listening to desantis
it's almost like oh there's something
sane
there's still something saying and by
the way
there's something saying that's what's
going to fix this thing and that's what
we got to be fighting for
like just sanity there's nothing radical
or evil or racist or homophobic or
islamophobic or transphobic
about anything that he said there okay
he wants girls
to compete against girls fairness for
women athletes
but that would be considered crazy right
wing stuff anyway
as you can see on this monday we still
got work to do and i
think i don't know maybe it's from red
hill and my brother-in-law
on friday or just being away from
politics for the weekend but i really
think we might be getting some wins here
i
i think some things like maybe this
thing whatever this thing that we're all
fighting that you guys can all see that
i i talk to so many of you about every
day
when i respond to people in the in our
local community like maybe the thing
that we can all see maybe it needed to
be brought out further
so we needed to get it to fully burst
forth to see what it is to see that
these people lie
about everything i tweeted it this
morning but it's like give me
give me something that someone on the
left
isn't lying about what position is there
of the left
that isn't based on a lie meaning it's
it's
either just outright false like america
is systemically racist or whatever
policy prescription
they have isn't just dishonest say 15
minimum wage which there's no economic
theory that shows it would make sense
putting aside whether it's fair and all
the things
everything they say is a lie and i think
at some point
the truth is incontrovertible like the
truth is
there it's there and we just got to keep
fighting for it and i think more and
more people
will wake up speaking of the truth if
you guys didn't see it i did this
really it was like the most joyous 10
minute interview i've ever done
with corey yeshua and his daughter uh
trent no not liberty royalty thank you
royalty liberty trinity she was in the
matrix i think
uh this was uh the duo they were in that
fantastic viral video
from last week where he's just a young
father telling his young daughter
that critical race theory's nonsense and
she just is telling you the truth about
kids they just want to be around good
people
and be nice and all this stuff so we got
to sit down with him
uh she did i said you know i want to
give you a hundred bucks to get whatever
you want because she was just so great
and she wanted a lamborghini which
was a bit of a stretch you know i mean
we get demonetized every now and again
that's
that's a bit much but i did get her an
american girl doll so i feel good about
that
uh also my full interview with kirk
cameron uh former 80s child star
turned like real sort of decent american
revolutionary cares about this place
let's fix this country kind of guy
our full sit down is up on youtube right
now oh and my
uh part one of my interview was so rob
amari which is a really really
interesting
interview he is the new york post one of
the new york post editors of the op-ed
pages and
just wrote a book called the unbroken
thread really really interesting guy
and we we come from very different
places but i think we've come to similar
conclusions
about the touch points on liberalism and
conservatism and what will kind of get
us through
all of this lying nonsense actually it
would be a perfect
follow-up for everything i talked about
today so part one
is on the youtube right now the full
interview is up ad free five days early
over at reubenreport.locals.com
and uh yeah as i said i'm going to
florida next week maybe we'll do a
locals meetup let me see if we can pull
up some time for that we'll see about
that
and uh i hope your monday is going well
enjoy the week we'll be back
tomorrow